[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
care less and today I bring you a statue
from one of Marvel's best rated and best
revered movies I bring you the statue of
Captain America from the Winter Soldier
yets version this statue is so
phenomenal sideshow did a great job with
this premium pulling that format and I
must go into why this statue is
purchased and how it came to be in my
collection but let's go over the origins
of this statue
and why it's so important so if you
didn't know Captain America the Winter
Soldier is a sophomore movie of Chris
Evans reprising his role as Captain
America the first movie Captain America
the First Avenger it was an origins tale
and it was a little slow a little
tedious it gave you the Red Skull and
the tesseract and stuff like that and
introduced a couple of things but
Captain America has always been intrical
in the Marvel Universe and I thought the
Winter Soldier actually showed you a lot
of firsts and a lot of things that
needed to be done and fleshed out
especially with this character to show
you it's his strength and his breath
right so let's get to a couple of
disease now Captain America
shows a lot of clothes
combat fighting techniques and what I've
noticed in that movie the cinematography
with the action and the visceral combat
was top-notch it's probably the best one
in the Marvel Universe when it came to
that close action combat and that's
where Captain America shines the most
like the scene where he's in the
elevator and he has over I had to be at
least 10 to 15 specially trained agents
fighting him in the elevator by himself
and Captain America upper seats to fight
them off they using stun weapons they
use in are trying to shackle them he
didn't even use his shield in that fight
in that elevator now the next scene
which I believe this is this is where
the statue gets its base from gets his
the toss gets the whole action scene
where they captured it from they they
knew that scene was very important as
the scene when the Quinjet comes to
confront Captain America as he's leaving
the shield building on his Captain
America motorcycles that I had when I
was a child um Captain America proceeded
to systematically break down I don't
know I guess those are those clean
gestures like a billion dollars army
tactical unit twinjet systematically
you're talking about the peak version of
a human being the absolute apex of a
fighter so when that scene was done and
rightfully so you must make a statue of
that that must be done you know a couple
of scenes where he was fighting the
Winter Soldier when he fought the Winter
Soldier when they were in the middle of
the street and you noticed that it had
nothing but tight combat in the middle
of the scene
the Winter Soldier flips the knife up
catches it in his hand to go from a
stabbing motion to like a downward
slashing motion and incredible fight
scene and you know Captain America at
that point in time weapon not in hand
the shield was off to the side was
holding his own incredible incredible
movie incredible statue
let's get into the statue let's get into
why that I said I needed to have this
statue
well the movie is the number one reason
and tool I started collecting the Marvel
Universe to emcee use universe sideshow
statues of like the Incredible Hulk I'm
still debating on that Thor that Thor
looked very bad an Iron Man that I got
and Captain America and I thought that
was important in my collection with this
one it was also important because they
debuted the stealth Captain America with
the stealth shield it it was amazing the
II explosion of this is amazing now I
must say I'm not a fan of the portraits
the portrait is an accurate portrait of
Chris Evans but the face is very stoic
it's very nonchalant if your interaction
polls put on the shield the same thing
with the mouth on the one with the
helmet on a very stoic face I would like
a grimace as he's tossing the shield but
they did get down the shield perfectly
they did with the base have the broken
Quinjet here is you're not gonna get a
full Quinjet and the base has descent to
up Sentinel Liberty right there you also
had got the new suit to infiltrate the
suit Wiggy full bow rock on top of the
ship when he infiltrated the ship it was
a lot of instances in that movie that
shows you how good the Captain America
really truly is the paint application on
the statue is really good it's top-notch
but at the same time it's very
simplistic so you have a lot of lines
that's inside and a lot of details that
you have to be up close now from a
distance it loses those details but when
you get up close on the Statue all the
details shine through it's very
simplistic but the devil is in the
details with this statue like the shield
on the chest the star on the chest it's
a very little minding details around the
star that you wouldn't see from a
distance but when you get up close on
the steps you can actually appreciate it
like the gloves and the fingertips it's
a very well-done statue very underrated
and it's also mixed-media all the
leather on the statue like the leather
on the belt the level on the straps in
the back on on the shield holder all
another on the Statue is actually
leather base so it's it's a very good
statute I'm not gonna lie I do have more
Captain America's that I am going to
show this is fundamentally probably the
best MCU Captain America not the best
Captain America from sideshow and
seven has a pretty good Captain America
as well so but I do actually love the
statute so this is the part in the video
where I'm gonna ask you to like follow
on subscribe and also go to loads of
gaming dotnet where we have a ton of
writer a ton of opinion pieces we have
all new consoles coming out this year so
anytime you want any new information on
any games coming out present or in the
future for the Lords of gaming that
meant where we are sure to make sure you
stay up to date and also watch lore
Cognito and Evon tits on the last word
destiny is in a transition going into
the september dlc big bang out right now
and they just released a new season so
right now I'm in the middle of the grind
of the season I'm trying to max out to a
hundred percent so you can catch me on a
destiny playing and also watching and
listening to the last word on everybody
ninja podcast it is the best to ham
destiny podcast that you didn't hear so
get a chance to go do that and also hit
that join button hey joy button you know
what that joint button is the joint
button is right there at the bottom and
when you hit the joint button you get a
chance to see all the stuff that has
afforded to members of the realm that
stuff in the background videos that we
do post you also give videos early you
have special emojis when you watch us
live on a Lords podcast Sunday at 1:00
p.m. it's been phenomenal and I can't
wait to bring your another statue next
week from my collection stay collected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]